okay so we're working on this dinging
[Music]
just work your basic
is that hard again hi
that's that keep the other hand alive
Joe don't have raised over here have her
go open there you see and then I come
around right this is where you would see
that little tilt that's where I start to
compress do you feel that and then this
yeah I start to reduce eye movement
boom and when we here start the little
tilt that is right there I start to
compress this hand starts to release
boom called cube Oh home there's the
tilt compress start to release this hand
into the turn okay tilt compress release
the other hand is not there where we can
control is okay
so the other hand is controls the
rotation but incrementally releasing
into the tech on not quite boiling but
this is there
okay so go ahead and go keep going and
don't turn your game you're not supposed
to do that you get it you you're not
turning you know where this technique
goes that you're turning for it that's
not where you're supposed to do okay go
don't turn me again
so if they're pulling your backwards
you're gonna just fall backwards
[Music]
the problem here is not understanding
credit you think you're giving yourself
too much credit for how powerful your so
the guy comes in and some energies going
that way and then what you're
understanding is that you stop him and
then you're gonna turn him you see that
and then he's gonna get up or better yet
you pick him up and then you go up you
guys see that
you got it so he goes and was like my
energy going that way you see it's not
so easy right and if I had 75 pounds or
100 pounds on and forget about it you're
not going to stop him and do that so the
problem is different from what you're
thinking the problem is how do I get his
energy that's going that way to go that
way okay you know you want to be facing
that way
but you're doing the obvious oh I'm
going to stop it and then I'm going to
turn it no we're not going to stop it
and we're not going to make it go that
way we're going to create a path of
least resistance and it'll be on that
spiral and his energy will fall into
that okay so I'm going to show you how
I'm doing it so this is part of the
beginning is long we've started a turn
here you see that so his energy is not
purely going straight it's already
started that angle which ends up being
taken that way so I'm starting to
believe off energy you understand
and I starts with the lead-off energy
then I bleed off even more because I
move over there so I'm not holding
against his initial line of attack you
see that okay I get his balance here and
for other reasons I don't want him
tilting like we correct it already so I
compress his spine all right now what
you guys want to do is turn him don't
don't turn him and see there's a lot of
strength right here you see hey it
reaches its limit so I can't keep
gaining a position of disadvantage along
that line so what I do is I take this
arm and start bleeding it off
so look house come over here just Lea
and push on my hat on that side please
and push on my hand so do you see okay
now watch what happens you see and so he
will do the turn you got to get that so
that's why we don't want to cut on that
hand it's doing the exact opposite so
there's a lot of integrity move right
there because that might be the knife
hand that I need to follow I come around
compress for other reasons and then I
start decreasing this this as I'm
continuing this pressure and he will
start to tilt and I follow the tilt so
that little tent on you see visit me 10
Comi to turn him and make him down it's
me turning to stay connected to him you
get up by releasing the pressure his
body now we'll tilt because there's
pressure on one side and there's
decreasing pressure on the other so the
energy will go out that way you
understand
so who won't change the situation
tilt and you just start decreasing this
Oh decreasing doesn't mean that I'm
taking my carpet in and now first and
foremost it means that it's better it's
gonna start relaxing start relaxing it's
already happening and then I change my
angle and you will go down and I follow
them down okay let's go I'm gonna lose
connection I don't take my hand off
[Music]
don't lose connection so stay there stay
on with her okay
and she should be here at this point and
you're pushing out don't let me push you
hold my weight okay and now you start
decreasing that pressure go and she will
turn got it you understand okay so she
shouldn't be there look she should be
here cuz that's where your Center is you
left her there
boom here you are start to decompress
now keep this strong look there's your
button relaxing for that on her strong
strong strong no it's not it's not cheap
extension on the earth you're pushing me
up push into her okay okay you separated
here but it strong out not up out out
out
her arm Hey
and then I started to decrease that
alarm I can only tell you like three or
four times that it's pointless okay go
you can change that it up you can lead
often up twelve to six energy you didn't
go in it enough in enough to get to the
other side of the apex of the circle try
to defend yourself try to defend
yourself picture starts to bleed that
off that's it you you guys are not
changing the additional relationships
enough actually need to get over here go
so you don't go to the shoulder
[Music]
see there's no connection do you see
that yeah no nothing to bleed off do you
understand
we were already disconnected so there's
nothing to bleed off okay you're hooking
her you're hooking her imagine she has a
knife you don't want to you want to keep
it out till compressed bleed off
[Music]
change partner don't get it going
don't hook his arm
[Music]
stay with her as she goes down follow
her down better
follow her down you're too far you're
pulling the opposite way because you
went you went into 12 you need to go to
three do you understand you get like
this if you go to 12 this energy has
gone the opposite way of that you have
to go around around him around him okay
that's right you want to get rid of the
12 spin we're going to cau I'm going
around okay let's go DK in your own
stepping create the conflict
turn with him no look don't look
he'll come press turn with him
change partners you're down there come
forward
[Music]
nope nope nope you got to get on this
side of the axis you get on the positive
side see you ask less of it nope nope
you got to get over here tilts back
compress start to bleed off follow him
down
you guys are getting pinned that's why
you can't follow people down you're not
able to get your ground path going tilt
tilt tilt happens on the forward
progress he's already taking don't pull
him backwards into the tilt
so watch what I mean there still happens
in the forward progress not backwards so
when I go like that DC you get it
because you're taking this energy and
you're keeping the head that upper part
of his body is on the smallest part of
the part of the spiral the lower part of
his body is on the longer part of the
spiral so eventually the head starts to
go backwards as the legs come forward
I'm not pulling the head back
I try to get this spiral going like that
you see
that's no different than when you're
doing coke you all your clothes you all
you go here wall and makes his head go
faster the same exact thing so don't put
me here and you go like this you're
going to do that that's no get your
spiral bull when you get down okay let's
go solve every conflict
[Music]
your feet under you we got more do
don't hook try to get his head to come
backwards by moving it forward into the
circle you are not over enough yes yes
come on you're you want to be on the
other side of his spine because the more
you're over here
the more you going the ass of yourself
force wise in order to turn this okay
leave it off
same same thing don't not just as you
can get yourself on the other side of
the of the axis do you understand Hey
one side of your body working and
one side not there's no way that could
be better
compressors finally time
just behind there breathe I don't hold
for lean change partners change location
let's go
get him to make the circle
so the reason why they're going face
down is well tactically that's a better
position for me okay but this takes more
energy to turn around if I allow her to
go backwards but to use her own
rotational torque it takes less energy
to get her to come around so no that
takes a lot more energy right you're
over here you're starting to turn are
you see and it doesn't take anything to
get her to go topsy-turvy to understand
what do you guys get that so around oh
and I'm just turning her then that it's
easy for her to fall when we don't put
our hand on the mat okay
[Music]
give us a rotation use the rotation
that's it well at the end you going to
this the fights over posture but get it
xisa and stay in peace right so holder
or her neck the other hand holds for
that keep consciousness drop the
technique ice cuz all hand will all have
no center hold their neck that's it
don't over lean right center
turn turn
you need to ask how come you always end
up on the shoulder
okay this rotate around this arm here
you see where am I
you guys are here here boom boom he
starts to stand up and I control his
asset but that's where we stop in
Virginia so go here whoa whoa hope he
stands up I like control this end get
his head on your shoulder we're not
doing the flip maneuver yet
geillis
you getting lost you getting lost
maintain consciousness
No
don't Beach down for her don't enter
trying to take away the last a muscle so
you know you're in the right ballpark no
you're gonna try to get up go slow go
slow so slower slower you'll turn and
then you'll stand yourself back up but
you are not to be face up Virginia there
you go
and you're not sitting up we're trying
to get up there you go
[Music]
turn you're not sitting up so a TV now
yeah is one of the few techniques where
you have a second role as you can so you
get up right because you're going to go
in the person who lays at the bottom
he lays there just come up in this come
up stop
[Music]
the person who sits up sit up the other
way sit sit up you see
sit up choke give my couplets House just
knock her down with your shoulder
it's taken a long time go go hog and
tackle pug leg leg
that's it
you get tackled put them in your clothes
card pick it up Maya legs dry foot up
the legs dry you got a duck your head
[Music]
closed guard you're gonna cross your
ankles so you don't get killed in the
street
lowest card fight on the way down what
what what drive with your name
it's goofy it out
virtually here legs but we should be
right
come on whoa we're get down get a foot
got it drive with that leg go drive
that's it got it if you don't do things
mechanically sound your hero weight
ratio goes down your power ratio goes
down go fight on the way down leg no leg
no leg you didn't use your leg
hey so if you got it it has the second
assignment to get up and that's where I
used up what I'm not pulling them back
he's ascending and I'm just guiding this
miss em how much can I pull you're going
to balance the vertical energy with your
horizontal energy and you do this if
you're gonna you don't shovel down all
the way you don't pull all the way
horizontally you're bleeding off both
energies to keep neutral pressure so
here he goes he has his second roll home
and I'm here no energy
pull up no energy
hey let's go hey
we did that
[Music]
you gotta be a match if you're not exam
you will not have a conviction if you're
right on this side there is no kuzushi
hi and you're in back because you're not
following them down
because on the other shoulder I didn't
throw you in each belt high
it goes on the other shoulder it goes on
the other focus hopes in it on your
shoulder don't look at them it's not
like we're doubting are you doubting me
then I don't need to say anything other
than that don't try to throw them does
it do it if they follow they fall
whether you're too far forward and
that's why your shoulder destination
does not generate position you
understand so you have to go back like
with all things right beginnings are
precarious thing so the mistakes is
earlier in the technique did you come
here you go like that do you see that
you did not follow him so look where my
shoulder is so he comes up and he's
really not off balance is he if he wants
to come in
so it's dark rewind the film so as I
come around watch what I'm going to do
hold here I follow him my shoulders over
here your shoulder was sitting there my
shoulders over here because he stands up
and I do that oh it's long way too
Michael
okay so if my shoulder is here even that
movement backwards is not enough
do you see not enough but if it was out
here and it moves by it is enough okay
go always a game of inches follow up in
the cozy she
[Music]
okay now to make sure I stay in the back
I add a 9/10
so I come around oh and I move over here
so I'm not here or I'm tired I'm going
to create space he gets up and I'm going
to move over here this great space for
his Kazushi and the second rotation
we're going one way now we're going to
go back the other way
no-ho-ho tilt whoa here you see that
whoa whoa I'm not moving my shoulder
from where it was so don't make this go
across the map it goes up to where it is
you see and right there so you can only
content to where you're not over asking
on the Kazushi to the shoulder
you can't fight and wherever you want
just right
[Music]
right okay get us there with the tight